yesterday four gymnasts testified about
the abuse they suffered at the hands of
larry nasser as the olympic team doctor
who's now in prison
where all sexual abusers should be
including the ones in the public school
system
and specifically they were talking about
how the fbi failed to help them or even
help to cover up the crime
so all of their accounts were
pretty shocking and important i'll play
one of them this is michaela moroney
talking about her experiences and
especially
the fbi's reaction or lack of reaction i
should say listen
good morning thank you chairman durbin
ranking member grassley and members of
the judiciary committee for inviting me
to speak today
as most of you are probably aware i was
molested by the u.s gymnastics national
team and olympic team doctor larry
nassar in actuality he turned out to be
more of a pedophile than he was a doctor
what i'm trying to bring to your
attention today is something incredibly
disturbing and illegal
after telling my entire story of abuse
to the fbi in the summer of 2015
not only did the fbi not report my abuse
but when they eventually documented my
report 17 months later they made
entirely false claims about what i said
after reading the office of inspector
general's oig report i was shocked and
deeply disappointed at this narrative
they chose to fabricate
they chose to lie about what i said and
protect a serial child molester rather
than protect not only me but countless
others
now as i said she was not the only one
to tell the same story about the fbi in
fact we have one more clip we'll play
the other one too uh because this is
important this is maggie nichols
with a disturbingly similar story to
tell listen
despite these findings of serious and
criminal misconduct throughout
the fbi usag and usopc no accountability
has occurred an important question
remains perhaps the most important
question why
why would the fbi agents lie to oig
investigators why would the fbi not
properly document evidence that was
received why would the fbi agent be
interested in the usag presidency these
questions remain unanswered
and the survivors of larry nassar have a
right to know why their well-being was
placed in the jeopardy by these
individuals who
chose not to do their jobs
to date no one from the fbi the us opc
or usag has faced federal charges other
than larry nassar for many hundreds of
survivors of larry nassar this hearing
is one of our last opportunities to get
justice
we ask that you
do what is in your power to ensure those
that engaged in wrongdoing are held
accountable under the law
yeah these i wish we could say these
claims are are shocking but
given what we know about the fbi
at this point they really aren't
what's being alleged here is the fbi
essentially participating
in a cover-up
of the uh the serial
abuse
sexual abuse of of
kids we have to understand the
corruption in our government
the rot in our government
is
incredibly deep
at every single level especially in the
federal government
which is why
in 2024
there's not going to be any
republican who can
solve all of these problems
but at a
minimum we talk about what we should be
looking for in a 2024 republican
candidate
one of the number one things we should
be looking for
is someone
who we have reason to believe
will get in there
and start
cleaning these people out
start sifting through all of this and
rooting through all of the corruption
and
holding these people accountable
or at a minimum getting them out
the you know that's that's a that's a
more wordy way of saying drain the swamp
which is what we heard about in 2016 and
um i think it was it was a good plan
it's a good motto it's a good plan it's
exactly what needs to happen it's very
swampy in dc and we do need to drain it
problem is that trump got in there in
2016. no matter how you feel about trump
there's no denying the fact that he
didn't drain anything he did not drain
the swamp at all he didn't get rid of
any of these people he didn't clean up
any of this
and he didn't try so you can't say well
he tried his best no he really didn't
what what did he do where's the evidence
that he tried to clean up any of this
mess
to locate
uh any of this corruption and expel the
people responsible for it
no he didn't because trump was
almost entirely concerned
with uh people that were you know
personal slights and personal attacks
against himself and responding to those
and that's it's fine to respond to
personal attacks
but we're also going to need a
republican who's focused on on a more on
a broader scale like cleaning up the
government
uh i think there's good reason to
to to believe in fact we know from what
we've seen ron desantis do in florida
that he will do that
even better that mayor in ohio i mean we
know he's gonna start arresting the
school board
it's that kind of aggressiveness that we
need if we're not going to get that
then you might as well not have a
republican at all
you know if if republicans
not going to start cleaning this up
then you we may as well not you might as
well just have a democrat
because then you have a republican
sitting atop this whole mountain of
corruption and filth
he's sitting atop this this
decaying
garbage heap
and if he doesn't get out a shovel and
start shoveling this stuff away
then he's going to be ineffectual as a
president and once he leaves that
garbage heap remains well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content